the story of the us fugitive who turned
up in glasgow has been a compelling one
for nobody more perhaps than the women
who count themselves as victims he's
brilliant and he's smart but at the same
time he's like wicked and malicious the
face on the interpol red notice is the
one known too well by mary whose
identity we're withholding
the mock shots are of nicolas rossi
convicted of sexually assaulting her in
ohio in 2008. he's holding me up against
the wall he has you know he's putting
his hands up my shirt and down my pants
and you know i i just want to leave um i
tell him you know i want to leave and he
tells me you know shut up i'm almost
done
could you take your losses off would you
mind we showed mary our coverage of the
man who insists he's the victim of
mistaken identity
she begs to differ
i know it's him he just he's got that
that dark hair and like those chubby f
like i would remember those like chubby
fingers anywhere you know they were up
my shirt they were down my pants like i
would recognize those anywhere like his
just greedy little claws
he insists his name is arthur knight but
the courts heard his fingerprints are a
match for the fugitive nicholas rossi
america wants him to stand trial on rape
charges in the state of utah the push
for extradition will be in the hands of
a scottish girl hang on mate
we walked in with massive suitcases and
then immediately insisted on sex
rossi turned up at michelle menard's
essex home in 2017 having met her online
in a month she says he ran up debts on
her credit card and only left after she
changed the locks
michelle found out in a google search
that she had a sex offender in the house
i did my own googling i found him
a mug shot of him on a
sex offender
uh
and i confronted him which he was very
surprised that i found it because he
said well oh how did you find this i
better need to take care of this so he
was like i think he was trying to get
himself removed from google search
listings
police in essex are now looking into a
complaint of historical rape and made by
michelle against rossie earlier this
year
this man's already been convicted for
abusing staff in a glasgow hospital he
was fined 400 pounds earlier this month
in court action to come the stakes are
rather high
james matthews sky news edinboro